well Conan yeah again I'm a guest on
your show right now and you're a guest
online yeah how are we gonna figure out
what part of this actually makes it tear
how do you know be fun so you you get
both sides and I get both sides we edit
it our way and you edit it your way and
we've and we compare later you know
we're gonna have two completely
different interviews you know it you're
not even gonna be in my version and
they're replacing with stock footage and
you know what it's gonna go viral the
next day I got I know you got a go but
how do you feel about entropy and the
march of time and the fact that even the
most beautiful things in the world
eventually grow old and decay just break
quick answer I find it relaxing
it's relaxing to know that all is
nothing it calms me good good good wow
that's a fun segment good luck with that
good luck with that one
you do your edit I'll do my listen we're
both the best we can in my I think it's
a time trying time so what is nothing
compared to what people are going
through we have those no is nothing
compared people going through this what
we're going through as celebrities is
worse than what anybody else is going
through I apologize I apologize I forgot
much thank you man I forgot my status
Conan you lost your perspective oh okay
goodbye god bless you I know I'm your
hero
take care how do you need me still or no
no no I'm just doing raps you can stay
if you want but I don't want to watch
this [ __ ] I've seen you right back with
more Conan O'Brien we'll be right back
with more Conan O'Brien how is that do
you like that those are awful maybe we
won't be back with more Connor
Hey hey everybody we're back with more
Conan O'Brien still their Idol their
hair I care show me what it's like to
care about a guest I want to know
I'll show you okay I don't want to leave
Steven but the network has business to
conduct so I have to go so we're gonna
take a break but when we come back and
we will come back I'm gonna spend more
precious time with Stephen Colbert he
means a lot to me
and I know he does to you well that's
how you care about a guest that's you
care oh there you go okay let me try it
again hey we're back
hey everybody you lucky people cuz Conan
O'Brien is still here there's an endless
supply of Conan O'Brien
he is our one renewable resource in this
country I say we go off oil and natural
gas we just start burning Conan
[Laughter]
congratulations you're now Stone
Phillips when we return I'll tell you a
chilling story about sitting naked on a
hotel bedspread that's my Christ even
I'm gonna leave you in peace no you
can't believe the bits have to keep
goodbye